[Music]
as part of our drive towards developing
an inclusive environment we wanted to
address both people's uniqueness and
their sense of belonging in order to do
that we needed to be able to have
conversations about somebody's
uniqueness in order to achieve a sense
of belongingness in the workplace and
therefore we felt like we needed to be
able to put on the table conversations
that were difficult topics that people
were wanting to shy away from maybe they
were worried about asking questions or
they were worried about bringing up the
topic but yet those topics were critical
to really understanding each other and
we launched a series called real talk
series in order to be able to put those
more difficult things on the table it
happened a little bit as coincidence
that there were a lot of current events
that occurred as we were going through
that Real Talk series things like
natural disasters a lot of the
immigration changes that were happening
in the US and then also the events that
happened in Charlottesville and those
became great platforms actually for us
to be able to have some of these
difficult conversations to understand
how people viewed things differently
so people may see an event like
Charlottesville and they feel badly
about it
they they're unhappy about it but they
sort of go on about their way whereas
other people in the workplace feel very
personally affected by it they they may
be angry they may be very sad about it
and they need to be able to come to a
workplace where people could recognize
those emotions and show that they cared
that they felt that way we wanted to
have our participants get comfortable
with the idea of being uncomfortable and
that was the guidance that we gave to
the leaders for those sessions to make
sure that we were raising up issues
where people understood that it wasn't
going to necessarily be an easy
conversation and people had to become
prepared to be vulnerable
and open to some level of discomfort one
of the things we asked for from the
participants was to assume a positive
intent and a positive intent is simply
necessary if you want to have these
difficult conversations and have them be
productive it's so easy to go in and
actually become defensive that's usually
the issue that creates the obstacles and
having a productive conversation it's
not so much that people go negative but
it's that they become defensive and so
we really asked people to come in and
say let's assume a positive intent on
the person on the part of the other
person so that we didn't go to an area
of defensiveness immediately as we
engaged in this series we wanted people
to understand it was a dialogue and not
a debate dialogue is open-ended it's a
conversation about how I might
experience something and understanding
how you might experience that exact same
thing but in a different way
in a debate you're looking to win you're
looking to convince and and have the
final say in something and that's not
the purpose of these conversations the
purpose is to make sure that we can
understand each other better and become
better advocates for each other all of
the experiences that we had going
through the Real Talk series really
thumbed up to leading people to commit
to having ongoing conversations about
things that matter even apart from the
series and it really led to a practical
take away for people to just simply say
I'm gonna sit down with somebody I'm
going to ask their perspective on on an
event that happened if something
happened over the weekend in the news
I'm going to commit to asking what was
their experience around that how did
they feel about it and what impact might
have had on them and to also sharing how
I might feel about it without judgment
as to what it should have been but just
understanding each of our own
perspective on that event so it was a
very good experience for us it was a
very significant impact for leaders in
the organization but also people who
were
participating in a serie in that series
as individual contributors to know that
leaders cared and wanted to engage in
those conversations
[Music]